Pengkomputeran kuantum dah masuk ke era utiliti
bermaksud kita boleh mula guna komputer kuantum untuk selesaikan
masalah dunia nyata termasuk yang sangat sukar
untuk komputer klasik
tema yang biasa dalam era semasa ni
adalah bila satu masalah diselesaikan
buat pertama kali pada komputer kuantum
dan kemudiannya orang jumpa cara nak buat dekat komputer klasik
kitaran klasik
dan pengkomputeran kuantum yang saling tolak antara satu sama lain ke had
masing-masing mungkin akan terus berlaku
untuk beberapa tahun lagi ada kelas-kelas masalah di mana kuantum
boleh beri kelebihan yang boleh dibuktikan
berbanding pengkomputeran klasik
memandangkan kemajuan dalam bidang seperti
pengurangan ralat dan bilangan qubit yang tersedia
ada juga keseluruhan kawasan aplikasi
di mana pengkomputeran kuantum
mungkin berguna dalam jangka masa yang agak dekat
salah satu kawasan ni ialah pembelajaran mesin kuantum atau QML
pembelajaran mesin kuantum merujuk kepada
penggunaan pengkomputeran kuantum untuk mana-mana jenis pembelajaran
mesin tentulah ada banyak jenis pembelajaran mesin
banyak jenis pembelajaran mesin
dua jenis yang menarik minat ialah
pembelajaran berpandu di mana kau
latih algoritma guna dataset berlabel
dan pembelajaran tanpa penyeliaan di mana
algoritma bekerja dengan sampel tanpa label
dan cuba belajar tentang taburan
atau fungsi yang menjana ia
algoritma tanpa penyeliaan mungkin
contohnya belajar cara jana sampel baru
daripada taburan yang sama atau cara nak
kelompokkan sampel ke dalam kumpulan dengan ciri-ciri yang serupa
pembelajaran berpandu dan tanpa penyeliaan selalu melibatkan
pembenaman data dalam ruang berdimensi tinggi
dan manipulasi data dalam ruang berdimensi tinggi
patut buat kita terfikir pasal pengkomputeran kuantum
biar aku jelaskan bayangkan nak selesaikan masalah sama ada nak
klasifikasikan satu titik data dari satah
sebagai bulatan atau silang berdasarkan data latihan berlabel ni
kadang-kadang data boleh diasingkan dengan jelas oleh satu garis
atau satah dalam dimensi rendah
seperti yang ditunjukkan di sini dan mengklasifikasikan titik data ni
kepada yang di atas garis
dan di bawah garis sepatutnya
tak ada masalah tapi tengok taburan ni
jelas takde garis yang nampak yang boleh asingkan titik data
tapi untuk data ni kita boleh bayangkan suatu
pemetaan dari dua dimensi ke tiga dimensi
supaya lepas guna pemetaan tu data kita nampak
macam ni dan ada satah yang jelas yang mengasingkan dua
kelas yang boleh kita guna
untuk klasifikasi kalau cara ni nampak terlalu mudah
kau memang betul kita tak boleh letak titik data yang kita nak
lebih tinggi tanpa sebab yang kukuh
mesti ada pemetaan
dari taburan 2D yang secara berkesan mengasingkan
titik data kita supaya kita boleh
guna pemetaan tu untuk klasifikasikan titik data baru
benda ni akan dibincangkan lebih lanjut dalam pelajaran yang beri gambaran semula
pembelajaran mesin tapi cukuplah kalau nak kata
bahawa masalah tu boleh dilihat
sebagai mencuba pelbagai pemetaan berbeza ke dalam dimensi yang lebih tinggi ni
untuk tengok pemetaan mana yang hasilkan yang terbaik
pengasingan titik data dari kelas yang berbeza
manipulasi data dalam dimensi yang lebih tinggi ni
adalah satu kawasan di mana pengkomputeran kuantum
mungkin beri kesan besar untuk faham kenapa
jom kita tengok semula perbezaan antara klasik
dan pengkomputeran kuantum
sama macam komputer klasik guna bit maklumat
komputer kuantum guna qubit
tapi untuk bilangan bit tertentu katakanlah empat
komputer klasik boleh ambil mana-mana daripada
dua pangkat empat atau enam belas keadaan yang mungkin
komputer kuantum juga boleh akses enam belas keadaan yang mungkin
tapi ia boleh wujud dalam superposisi semua
enam belas keadaan serentak
dan operasi boleh dilakukan ke atas keseluruhan superposisi ni
untuk empat qubit ni mungkin tak nampak
macam besar hal tapi bayangkan apa yang boleh dibuat dengan
komputer kuantum dalam dua pangkat dua puluh atau
dua pangkat satu ratus dua puluh tujuh
keadaan serentak ada banyak lagi perbezaan lain
antara pengkomputeran klasik dan kuantum yang akan
semua memainkan peranan dalam subjek ni
keadaan kuantum ada amplitud kebarangkalian kompleks
manipulasi sistem kuantum dijalankan dengan
operator unitary dan komputer kuantum terdedah kepada jenis
hingar yang berbeza berbanding komputer klasik
perbezaan-perbezaan ni akan muncul
sepanjang kerja pembelajaran mesin kuantum kau dalam bidang
macam pengekodan data pemetaan ciri dan mitigasi ralat
dalam sesetengah kes perbezaan antara klasik
dan komputer kuantum ni bagi kita reka bentuk sepenuhnya
algoritma baru tadi tu cuma gambaran ringkas je
tentang gabungan dua bidang yang sangat rumit
tapi semoga dua benda ni jelas
pembelajaran mesin selalu selesaikan masalah
dengan memanipulasi data dalam dimensi yang sangat tinggi
dan kedua komputer kuantum sangat sesuai
untuk memanipulasi data dalam dimensi tinggi
dan buat tu secara berbeza daripada sistem klasik
ini sepatutnya bagi kau rasa
kenapa pembelajaran mesin adalah bidang yang menjanjikan
untuk penggunaan pengkomputeran kuantum yang berguna